okay thanks for sticking around for the
last talk of the day my name is Dean
Overland I work at Microsoft and I've
actually been working on Python stuff at
Microsoft since 2005 as crazy as that
kind of seems so today I'm going to talk
about building a jit for Python and this
is a jit for C Python actually so this
is you know I think the reason for this
might be kind of obvious to a lot of
people but it's really to improve
performance of C Python and what really
inspired me to do this was there's a
talk at PyCon this year at the language
summit where Larry Hastings was asking
what can we do to improve adoption of
Python 3 and I think one way to do that
is to improve performance and kind of an
obvious way to improve performance is to
adage it to Python shits have been used
in a lot of places to improve
performance I think everyone knows and
has seen what's happened with JavaScript
over the past several years as the
different browser implementations have
gotten extremely competitive with each
other and have been working on better
and higher performance jits for their
javascript implementations that even has
translated over to the server side where
you have things like nodejs which has
adopted javascript as its programming
model we even see languages like Java
which we don't think of as dynamic
languages benefiting from jits in a lot
of ways where they can take what is more
static code but still somewhat dynamic
via virtual function calls and greatly
enhance the performance of their own
code by idina at run time instead of
compiling that have time and I also just
kind of think compilers are fun before
I've worked on Python tools for visual
studio at Microsoft I worked on
ironpython which is a python
implementation which was did it using
the CLR and before that I actually
worked on the CLR itself and so I really
kind of like these low-level things and
so I've been working on Python tools for
visual studio and some
service stuff recently and this is a fun
way for me to get back to the sort of
roots so my plan was fairly simple you
know python has a byte code based
interpreter and dot net actually has a
byte code based interpreter pythons byte
code is much higher level than Nets it
has things like op codes for addition
which are very high level and operate on
all sorts of objects whereas dot nuts
has addition but it's really adding two
numbers and the other interesting thing
is Microsoft just recently open sourced
their the clr the entire stack including
a relatively new jet called ryujin so
it's thinking well they're both
stock-based this should be pretty easy I
can just translate between them I just
have to go through and do the work and
it should be pretty straightforward and
along the way hopefully I can also come
up with a standardized jit interface for
C Python so that other people can plug
in jets as well so it's not just this
one jet and maybe you can get some of
that competitive spirit that we see
going on in the JavaScript and browser
space so i picked core clr for several
reasons the first is it really is a jit
it's designed to compile methods quickly
with little overhead and that's in
contrast with the clr used to have for
64-bit jet which was actually based upon
a full compiler and that was slow I saw
that when i worked on ironpython our x86
performance and when you when it came to
startup was still kind of terrible
compared to C Python but when you looked
at x64 it was a travesty so the fact
that the clr through this out and
started with a new jet that was designed
to be a real jet was promising and you
see a lot of other attempts to do jets
for Python for other things no longer
will use llvm llvm is there it's a nice
common compiler infrastructure but it's
a real
and it suffered from the same problems
or suffers from the same problems that
the see large it really suffers from
before they rewrote it the other nice
thing about the clr jet is it has
support for both object-oriented api's
where you can do things like virtual
function calls but it also has support
for low level primitives so one of the
goals early on with the clr was the
ability to call compiled C++ code down
you just take any random program I think
they demoed quake being recompiled into
il and it all just worked and the JIT
can compile it and so my implementation
is actually not using any of these
object-oriented opcodes at all it uses
call to call methods but other than that
it's generating a bunch of pointer
arithmetic style code so the other thing
about core CLR is I knew that we could
get good performance from the jet and
that was from my work with ironpython
where we actually had some really nice
numbers coming out of it it was not good
on startup costs and that was something
that we tried to fight over and over and
over again but the nice thing about C
Python is we can keep the eval loop
which starts up extremely quickly and
then jit methods as they become hot and
you know I obviously know IL I know the
CLR i worked on the CLR team before i
started doing python stuff and I just
thought it was kind of cool that we open
source the CLR and I could use it and
then I keep mentioning the open sourcing
of the CLR and the key thing here is I'm
not actually taking the CLR that's
sitting on your machine and using that
compile code I actually rebuild the CLR
the JIT is actually its own dll if you
have a Windows machine have the CLR on
it but you can compile it into its own
lib its standalone I statically linked
that into my pie dll and it's just a
small dll which is a standalone jit at
that point the CLR team is working on
porting the jet over to mac OS x and
linux and so this will actually all be
cross-platform at some point as well
and of course you're thinking whole
[ __ ] Python that's been done before
right and it has been done but I think
people always kind of go off in weird
directions I'm trying to go off in a
slightly different direction so of
course there's numba which is llvm based
and I mentioned kind of how full
compilers are a little bit slow to start
up it's also focused more on numeric
code and so I want to focus on just the
ability compile any old Python code but
it is the most active jet implementation
for C Python right now there is unladen
swallow which also focused on llvm and
in fact they working when the first
consumers of llvm as a jit and they had
to fix tons and tons of bugs in llvm to
make it a successful jet and Google
ended up walking away from that project
after they weren't quite able to get the
performance gains they wanted their
psycho which is no longer under active
development but it was the first Python
jet it did its own custom code
generation which I think in some ways is
a little bit scary it's kind of a
maintenance nightmare it's going to be
difficult to port things to new
platforms because you have to go and
rewrite your code generator again and I
just kind of don't really want to go
down that route and ultimately that was
replaced by pi pi which is a scary in
its own way but still extremely
successful so pi PI yeah obviously the
fastest Python implementation that's out
there they suffer a little bit from
startup time but it's nothing like a lot
of the other llvm based implementations
and they also have their own custom [ __ ]
that they have to maintain and it's a
different Python implementation so you
kind of give up everything that you know
and love like your C extensions might
work but you definitely have to rebuild
them and that can be said for ironpython
enjoy on and piston which is another new
implementation you know there's
advantages to go into new implementation
so ironpython in json kind of
you the best of their underlying VMs and
all those libraries but sticking to see
python has a bunch of advantages and
just you get absolute compatibility and
you get everything that is actually out
there so one of my goals here was to
come up with a jit interface and right
now that is extremely simple there's a
function to initialize the jet which
currently is invoked at startup time but
that's probably a bad idea and that
might go away who knows there's a
function to eval a piece of code that
has been compiled and so when you
compile a piece of code you get a pie
code object and return this function
pointer that C Python can call in place
of doing its normal Val this takes a
frame object and that might seem a
little bit weird and that really to get
good performance out of a jit you want
to get rid of the frame objects entirely
but there needs to be something that
comes in for that first invocation and
from then on out the jit can actually
start doing calls between functions
getting rear frame objects and not
creating them inline functions and all
of those good things so I think this is
a good common starting point and then
I've jit free here you know we've got to
clean up at some point but I don't
actually do anything with that yet so
that's kind of to do there's probably
some more things that will need to be
defined for jit interface we might want
to have some sort of annotation system
so you see this a number where you can
say this actually takes these specific
types there's ants or you know bowls or
strings or whatever and the JIT can
generate more optimal code but I really
kind of hope that won't become necessary
something that unladen swallow looked at
doing which is actually really useful is
having callbacks for when dictionaries
change that you can invalidate code so
that rather than assuming you know that
range you have to check to see if you're
calling range and if you are then you're
actually going to get an iterator of
numbers you can just discard that code
and not do any checks in line so those
are useful for both the built-ins
dictionary as well as the Global's
dictionaries a function to call to
continue evaluation of a frame so
sometimes you may be running optimal
code and your assumptions aren't true
anymore and it would be nice not to have
to generate fullback codes that you get
more dense code that has better
abilities fit inside of caches and being
able to just fall back to the Python jit
and say hey evaluate my stuff here I was
last at this OP code thanks and then
finally something that we saw in
ironpython was that sometimes you'll
have code that spends all of its time in
a function and it's just looping inside
of that top-level function and you
really want to compile that loop I'm not
quite sure what this looks like in order
to avoid not adding significant overhead
into C Python normally but that would be
something that's pretty useful as well
ok so what does this end up looking like
here's a simple function it adds two
numbers and returns them and Python the
bytecode is extremely simple so it loads
a loads be calls the binary add opcode
and it returns the value so we translate
that into dotnet bytecode and it gets a
little big so that's what that ends up
looking like i'll just let you read and
soak that in got it ok cool so i'm not
going to go through this OP code by
opcode or anything insane like that
because well i don't want you to all run
out so instead let's look at kind of
what's going on to actually generate
this code and so this is the source code
from the JIT itself and the first thing
that we ended up generating is actually
a method prologue and one of the things
that I've tried to do is just make cheat
code work exactly like unjaded code so
this first bit
if you've ever looked at a Python frame
object it has the last op code that was
executed in it and so we pull the
address of that variable out of the
frame object and store it as a local so
we can update it whenever we need to and
then the first thing that the PI eval
function in C Python does is it pushes a
frame and so we go off and do that the
next thing that we're going to do is
load those two variables right and this
is actually represents a good chunk of
the code that you saw on that screen a
lot of it is kind of unnecessary we know
that those parameters will never not be
assigned but right now I've done no real
optimization on the JIT whatsoever and
so this is pulling out the local from
the frame object and one interesting
thing is that our locals are still in
frame objects so if we went off and you
know called in to something that called
sista yet frame down the stack they
could go up and they could find the
locals and pull them out right now and
that's a potential place of optimization
in the future but then we go off and we
actually check to see if the local is
set or not if it was null the locals not
defined and we're going to have to raise
an exception it would be very easy to go
through and know if a local is never
deleted that it's always going to be
assigned it's a little bit more
difficult for non-locals because you
have to understand the flow control of
the function but our for non parameters
so that's a simple optimization that can
be done which will reduce the code in
the future finally we dupe the value on
the.net stack and we call ink ref on it
which consumes one of the values and the
variable that we loaded was left next we
do at hey that's easy it's a method call
so all the operators are basically this
easy we have two values on the stack and
we can just call into a helper method
which calls into a method in C Python
which does the addition now the addition
can fail it can raise an exception in
which case it will return
all and so we have Chuck air which we
call which is actually a good going to
do the null check and raise the
exception and this is what check air
looks like so it's going to compare see
if the value is null if it is then it's
going to branch around otherwise it's
going to branch to a label where we
actually raised the exception at there's
this to do here right now so if you know
II was not defined after a plus B we
would have pushed a onto the stack and
we have to deck refe and that doesn't
happen right now so that's still kind of
a outstanding thing to do although it's
just a little bit of work so you know it
leaks a little bit of memory
occasionally when you're throwing
exceptions and I mentioned last I before
updating that we don't have to update
last I all the time there's instructions
that can't possibly fail and the user is
never going to see last I in that case
and so if it's something like doop we
aren't going to actually update that
again and again again for no useful
purpose so sometimes we update these and
burn them in hopefully we can get
smarter about this and get rid of this
to at some point but right now
compatibility was my main goal and
getting everything working so I wanted
to show you that was add and everything
we generate for ad but I wanted to show
a couple of other examples of how we
compile things loading Constance is kind
of interesting if you ever looked at a
code object it has a CO const field on
it and things like none and want like if
you put one in a method those are all
going to be stored in this tuple thats
hanging off of the code object and the
nice thing here is we can just burn the
address of that object directly into the
generated code so it's just a x86 or x64
assembly instruction that's going to get
generated that holds directly onto the
address of that object and we have to
Inc rough it because we have to rough
count all over the place loading names
you know this is looking up a global for
example or a
nonlocal potentially anything that isn't
resolved into a if you're inside of a
class variable lookups have to happen
dynamically into a dictionary and so in
this case you again we're just burning
the address of the name object which is
a string object and we're calling this
one helper method to do the name lookup
and then if it fails overturned all we
have to check it and all of that good
stuff load attributes similar to loading
names except for we have an object that
we're loading it from that was already
pushed onto the stack and we call the
helper method and Kennedy you can see
the pattern here so a lot of this code
generation is actually really simple and
straightforward which is kind of what I
was expecting when I got started with
the project well there were challenges
and the first big one is really
exception handling which is a bit of a
mess and as I mentioned with the deck
ref issue still isn't quite entirely
solved but it's pretty close iteration
was another one there's a little bit of
funkiness around there and returning
break and continue become kind of fun
especially in the face of exception
handling so with exception handling
we've seen all the little error checks
that are sprinkled throughout the code
those aren't really too bad they're just
checking for null and then branching to
a common label usually and so they're
not contributing a lot to code bloat the
real interesting thing about exception
handling is that C Python actually has a
second stack that it maintains that's
there for both loops and exceptions and
so that's a big difference from dotnet
where there's really just a single stack
the worst thing about that second stack
is well there's two bad things a the
stack depth ends up varying based upon
the opcodes which is something that
dotnet doesn't like and the two stacks
are a little intertwined and you could
actually construct bytecode by hand
which C Python looks cute in a perfectly
reasonable way
that is going to interact with those two
stacks in a very bizarre way if you pay
attention to what the C Python bytecode
compiler is actually doing it will never
produce those bizarre sequences of op
codes so we cheat and there's actually
you can actually compile function by
hand and pass in the bytecode by string
and create a function that horrible
horrible things would happen to us with
and kind of the supreme example of this
is the in finally opcode which behaves
in a whole bunch of different ways so
this is what a simple try finally with
no statements inside of it and see
Python compiles into it first does a
setup finally which pushes a block onto
the block stock pot block pops it off
and controls just flowing through here
so we completed the try successfully
with no exceptions so now we hit this
load const which is loading none you
don't see this none anywhere in your
code but it's there and it's there so
that in finally can consume it and say
no exceptions happened I'm just going to
continue on to my next opcode and we'll
load constant return none as the default
return value for a function so in
finally popped one value from the stack
but an finally can behave a little bit
differently so here we have in finally
inside of a loop and we're breaking from
the loop in the try block so we have our
setup loop we have our setup finally we
have the break flute break blue is
actually going to push an integer onto
the Python stack you don't see it I
don't remember what the number is its
some bit flag and we're going to pop the
block which pops the well we're not
going to hit the pop block because break
loop is actually going to dispatch to
the end finally as it pops the block
stack so we go into n finally with this
value on the stack and finally sees it
pops it and knows that it needs to pop
another
block from the block stack and then that
happens and it knows where to jump to
and so that's kind of another oddity but
in finally can pop multiple values in
the case of a return and here when we do
the return it's going to push us that
same special integer that says what's
going on kind of oil it like what braked
it but it's a different integer value
and it's going to push the return value
onto the stack and then we're great
dispatched in finally and it's going to
pop two values off the stack and then
yet another case is if we end finally in
an exception block so what's really
weird here is we have an in finally
opcode but there's no set up finally I
mean it just doesn't exist we're ending
a finally that was never there and it
just seems like someone had this
complicated in finally opcode that could
easily be overridden so what goes
through is we are doing the match to see
if we have an exception and if we don't
match the exception then we'll pop
forward to the end finally and the
exception will be re raised so what's on
the stack in this case is actually three
values you can see the three pop tops
there there's an exception value an
exception type and a trace back so I
don't know how crazy that seems to you
but the big problem here is that the
dotnet IL definition is designed to be
verifiable and it's designed to know
what's going on and be able to track
values through the system and say hey
you messed up a type here C Python
doesn't have those constraints obviously
so with net you cannot vary the stack
depth based upon control flow based upon
values that are on the stack and if you
do the JIT is going to blow up and it's
not going to know how to generate code
and so somehow we actually have to make
all that work and the way that works is
you know we can see these set up except
we can see these set up finally op codes
and we can
manifest that same block stack at
compile time just like C Python does at
runtime except for if there is crazy
control flow crazy weird bytecode not
produced by the compiler we're going to
get very confused about how we manifest
that block stack at compile time another
fun thing is actually iteration so in C
Python when you do forex in something
the first thing that happens is there's
a get it or opcode which gets generated
and then the second thing that happens
is there's a four-hitter opcode and it's
just going to loop around and call for
it or on the inner value that came back
from get it or over and over and over
again and it's going to leave that
iterable value on the stack throughout
the entire iteration this is a a little
bit weird in that for a door will
eventually pop that value off the stack
and dispatch to the end of the loop
that's not particularly a huge problem
what's kind of confounding here is that
dot net is very restrictive about
leaving basic blocks with values on the
stack in certain cases and kind of the
canonical one of those is returning with
a value so if you're iterating over
something you do return X and you have
something on the stack it is not happy
that might just be it being a little
over restrictive but that's kind of one
of the limitations there and so in a lot
of cases we have things like this jump
absolute opcode and for every opcode we
have a label that we define for IL and
if we need to jump to it we jump to this
spot where that label is with for it or
we actually have to get that value off
the stack and so we store it into a
local and then that table needs to be
slightly adjusted so that instead of
branching to the instructions that we
start admitting when we're in counting
for it or we're branching to a couple
instructions later which are actually
just after we've loaded the iterable
value out of a local
it's a little annoying and certainly not
the worst thing in the world but get it
or in for it aren't actually always
paired they can show up not being paired
in the case of a list comprehension so
it gets a little bit complicated the
other fun thing is a break return and
continue which all need to be aware
finally block Sweeney dispatch through
them so C Python ends up pushing these
special values onto the stack these
integer values and when it hits the in
finally it checks for those and then
dispatches out to the block stack and so
when we hit a break tenure return we
actually have to go through the block
stack and add dispatches out into the
final ease and we do the same trick
actually like our in finally blocks when
you're pushing special values on the
block and our finally blocks are always
expecting to start with one value on the
stack and they'll check that value and
then break continue or return the nice
thing is we can detect whether or not
there's break continues or returns
inside of these blocks and we can get
rid of those checks entirely if we don't
need them so that was just one more
wrinkle and exception handling and it
took lots and lots of iterations of
getting that all right and just it's
like oh yeah got it right nope all right
nope so that was a lot of fun so the
real interesting question is what does
the perfect like so i started this back
in at PyCon actually and i was able to
get two numbers being added at PyCon and
i've been working through flushing out
support for all the other byte codes
just about and I've had no chance to
really dig in and do any optimization
work my focus has been on completeness
so on this graph numbers below the line
are better numbers above the line
are worse and numbers obviously on the
line have no change so there's a few
things that got fifteen twenty percent
perf benefits I left off start up on
here cuz startup takes a big hit right
now these numbers are we are jetting
methods after they've been invoked 20
times which is a rather low number and
so that probably impacts startup really
horribly but may make some of these
numbers a little bit better for the perf
runs actually so there's a lot of things
that can still be done and I'll talk
about those in a second but I think one
important thing is what is the overhead
of actually getting code and that is
it's about 22 times slower to execute a
empty method if we have to get it on its
first invocation and that is actually a
really decent number so I've looked at
some llvm implementations and it ends up
being over a thousand times slower this
will probably get worse as more
optimizations get added in as we have to
do some passes through the methods but I
don't expect it to get too much worse
and so I think that leaves a lot of hope
for this implementation so there are
some things that we don't actually
support yet yield and yield from are too
kind of difficult ones they shouldn't be
too bad and that we just need to really
set up the state machine and switch and
branch to the opcodes after the yield
opcode the only difficult thing there is
restoring values that were on the stack
so if you do a plus yield some value and
have a someone sending a value back in a
needs to be stored on the stack and it
needs to be restored when you come back
in so that will be a little bit
difficult and will probably be the last
thing to actually be supported with
statements aren't supported the
dimensional exception handling is hard
so I
don't think the with statement will
actually be too much more difficult but
I'm sure there will be some surprises
there and then of course the
user-generated bytecode which we have no
way to detect and we'll just kind of
make us crash and burn in horrific ways
so I don't really know what to do about
that so there's a lot of low-hanging
fruit that can be improved upon so
there's some things like you will
compare two values and then do a value
it check if the the same right our check
if it's true so a equals B is this true
and in those cases we can merge those
opcodes into one piece of generated code
and we would avoid pushing a true on to
the stack bumpiness ref count popping a
true off the stack decking it's ref
count and so on so that is a pretty
simple optimization which can be added
in we lost C Python has an optimization
which is there to reuse strings like
when you're doing a can cat and optimize
the memory allocations there and we lost
that I mentioned the checking to see if
parameters were defined doing that with
parameters will be really easy locals
will be more difficult but i'll probably
do parameters pretty quickly there's a
larger stuff so type specialization if
we look at the values that are coming in
you know if they were in suis could
generate simple in addition check for
overflow and return a new int rather
than dealing with a bunch of Python
objects and as that expands it becomes a
more important optimization and doing
inference to detect all that stuff poly
mono and polymorphic inline caches
that's something that we used a lot in
ironpython and so that is the ability to
do some in lining of the code that you
expect to be there do a quick type check
and if the types correct then you can
just go off and do whatever you need to
do to make that happen instead of
dispatching to a larger chunk of code so
that will let things like inline happen
potentially
and you know for operations like
addition those could be in mind as well
tagged pointers this just lets you get
rid of allocations for things like entz
and so rather than allocating a PI
object which is going to store a simple
int you can have an object where the
lowest bit is set on it because all
objects have 0 bits set further those
bits and you can have 31 bits of integer
63 bits of integer stored there and we
can do this by passing our variables out
by ref and if we need a box them we
replace the tag pointer with a real
pointer before calling you the Python
runtime and we don't allocate too many
objects almost done iteration
optimizations you know range avoiding
allocating it or iterator objects for
those I think that is that's something I
started looking at but just haven't made
much progress in lining kind of
combining with type specialization
moving things off of the frame object
into locals and the loop compilation
which I have no clue how to do that with
Python and long term but that's it if
there's any questions I'll be happy to
answer them I posted the code at github
on my github repo I called it pigeon
just kind of like unladen swallow but
it's a different bird and it sounds like
pie jit kind of brett
so obviously the number is some of them
look good some of them don't you have
any feeling how much of the lower
hanging we'd have to get cleared out in
order to make it pretty much across the
board equivalent and the almonds like is
that far as you just going to target
2020 I so I think changing the 20 hits
will help on start up a huge amount I
think that number should be a lot bigger
to help start up it's kind of a
ridiculously low number i know unladen
swallow was doing 10,000 so i think
there's you know like some of the going
back to the performance benchmarks some
of the really bad ones were calls which
seemed really surprising to me those are
the ones on the Left which are the worst
here and I think those will be some of
the easiest things to actually optimize
there are actually a couple of
benchmarks that are missing because I
crash on them right now so I I don't
think it's that far off from getting
something that's like parody Travis this
does nothing with the gill so kind of I
think one of the benefits of adding
image it to see python is that the rest
of the world doesn't have to change and
and that's a good thing in some ways the
gills going to be a different nightmare
to get rid of and this would play fine
with the gill or without the gill ref
County obviously has to be solved for
the gill and it will impact things
either way and whatever solution happens
there should be easy to add it to the
jib stroke
yes in theory that will all happen I
don't know what the effort where the
efforts to port course ELR to mac OS x
and linux are right now in fact i snap
back to an old version of course ELR so
it may be there I just haven't gone back
and checked but they are absolutely
porting to linux and mac OS x and so
we'll be able to benefit from that work
yes yep nope so what you want is Python
net so Python net make sure I think you
need to find the github page if you
search for it you're going to get some
old page but it's available it's still
being maintained it has an interface
it's very similar to ironpython where
you can do import clr see lara add
reference and it's a bridge between
python and net and so it's using the
Python the.net hosting api's yeah yeah
find the new one it someone picked it up
so compatibility should be perfect
modulo lots of bugs that I still have
the work out there's nothing in this
which breaks compatibility in any way
shape or form we are basic right right
now it basically is unrolling the Python
of a loop and so it will be executing
the same in the same basic manner just
faster hopefully brett sure there's
instructions a short read me on how to
set things up it will download the
dependencies source code on github is
just the JIT itself it will get Python
and core clr and sink them back to the
change that I tested and apply some
small changes so that you get the jit
interface and then you can build them
and those are woefully under tested so
report any issues quick question not
directly related this talk but there's
Dropbox has another yes that's piston
and it's a brand new Python
implementation which is a little bit
crazy but what was the difference for
the uninitiated we're doing so they have
to go and recreate everything Python and
get it perfect the entire run time they
want to put in a conservative GC they
went to their jit is based on llvm which
is going to have the same slow startup
costs that lvm has and it's just a huge
amount of work for them to get from
point A to point B to recreate all the
work that the Python devs have been
working on for the past decades this is
C Python with a new dll and maybe a 30
lines of code change and C Python to
call into the generated code yes yes and
in particular like there's no reason to
get a module right now I started off
getting all the modules just to kind of
work through the code there's almost no
reasons to get a class definition you
could run a class definition in a loop
and be dynamically generating classes
which are closed over things and maybe
that might matter at some point to
someone but it's pretty unlikely and
yeah and so we just get the methods that
get invoked enough times which is
currently 20 all right no more questions
thank you very much
you